[Music]
it wasn't expecting the ending that we
got but it was immensely satisfying to
me the leftover star Carrie [ __ ] is
opening up to ET about the HBO dramas
3rd and final season especially
gratifying to have Norah be so much a
part of the ending and also challenging
as an actor just because of the actually
the volume of things I had to learn
there at the very very end and we were
exhausted and there's actually quite a
bit of stunt work in that last part to
that I got to do myself and so in some
ways it was great to be so mentally and
physically exhausted by the last episode
it just seemed like an approaches to
leave it all on the table was the only
way to finish the series Carrie will
soon be back on our screens and the
upcoming season of Fargo and she said it
was actually easy for her to perfect
that iconic accent why don't you serve
in the beginning this fella comes in and
wants that case a frozen orange juice
concentrate which is that can you make
map from that not last I heard I got my
MFA at the UW wisconsin-madison and a
lot of people from Minnesota are there
and the dialect is very close in fact I
remember being in a shoe store one of my
first few some weeks of the summer in
Wisconsin and I heard someone go oh for
cute and I turned around I thought is
that an actual exclamation and of course
it is it's very real though those people
are it's real that's a real wonderful
friendly specific thing up there and I
love it what can we do for you friend I
hate to just pile on to the hagiography
of you and McGregor but unfortunately he
is as delightful as everyone says and
then he's playing these two brothers
with very different personalities and
he's making them very distinct and you
just fall in love with both of them and
him it's a triple threat it's horrible
you
you